[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chapter 11.
once inside in her flat or rather
in the flat that was not hers coraline
was pleased to see that it had not
transformed into the empty drawing that
the rest of the house seemed to have
become
at a depth it had shadows
and someone who stood in the shadows
waiting for coraline to return
so you're back said the other mother
she did not sound pleased
and you brought vermin with you
no said coraline i brought a friend
she could feel the cat stiffening under
her hands
as if it were anxious to be away
coraline wanted to hold on to it like a
teddy bear
for reassurance but she knew that cats
hate to be squeezed and she suspected
that frightened cats were liable to bite
and scratched if provoked in any way
even if they were on your side
you know i love you said the other
mother
flatly you have a very funny way of
showing it
said coraline she walked down the
hallway
then turned into the drawing room steady
step
by steady step pretending that she could
not feel the other mother's blank black
eyes on her back her grandmother's
formal furniture was still there
and the painting on the wall the strange
fruit but now the fruit and the painting
had been eaten
and all that remained in the bowl was
the browning core of an apple
several plum and peach stones and the
stem of what had formerly been
a bunch of grapes the lion pod table
raked the carpet with its clawed wooden
feet as if it were impatient for
something
at the end of the room in the corner
stood the wooden door
which had once in another place opened
onto a plain brick wall
coraline tried not to stare at it
the window showed nothing but mist
this was it coraline knew
the moment of truth the unraveling time
the other mother had followed her in now
she stood in the center of the room
between coraline and the mantelpiece and
looked down at coraline with black
button
eyes it was funny
coraline thought the other mother did
not look
anything at all like her own mother she
wondered how she had ever been deceived
into imagining a resemblance
the other mother was huge her head
almost brushed the ceiling
and very pale the color of a spider's
belly
her hair writhed and twined about her
head and her teeth
were sharp as knives
well said the other mother sharply
where are they coraline leaned against
an armchair
adjusted the cat with her left hand put
her right hand into her pocket
and pulled out the three glass marbles
there were a frosted gray
and they clinged together in the palm of
her hand the other mother reached her
white fingers for them
but coraline slipped them back into her
pocket
she knew it was true then the other
mother had no intention of letting her
go
or of keeping her word it had been an
entertainment
and nothing more hold on
she said we aren't finished yet
are we the other mother looked
daggers but she smiled sweetly
no she said i suppose not
after all you still need to find your
parents
don't you yes said coraline
i must not look at the mantelpiece she
thought i must not even think about it
well said the other mother
produce them would you like to look in
the cellar again
i have some other interesting things
hidden down there
you know no
said coraline i know where my parents
are
the cat was heavy in her arms she moved
it forward
unhooking its claw from her shoulder as
she did so
where it stands to reason
said coraline i've looked everywhere
you'd hide them
they aren't in the house
the other mother stood very still giving
nothing away
lips tightly closed
she might have been a wax statue
even her hair had stopped moving
so coraline continued both hands wrapped
firmly around the black cat i know where
they have to be
you've hidden them in the passageway
between the houses haven't you
they're behind that door she nodded her
head
toward the door in the corner
the other mother remained statue still
but a hint of a smile crept
back onto her face oh
they are are they
why don't you open it said coraline
they'll be there all right it was her
only way home
she knew but it all depended on the
other mothers needing to gloat
needing not only to win but to show that
she had one
the other mother reached her hand slowly
into her apron pocket
and produced a black iron key
the cat stirred uncomfortably in
coralline's arms
as if it wanted to get down just stay
there for a moment longer
she thought at it wondering if it could
hear her
i'll get us both home i know i said i
would
i promise she felt the cat relax
ever so slightly in her arms
the other mother walked over to the door
and pushed the key into the lock
she turned the key coraline heard the
mechanism clunk
heavily she was already starting
as quietly as she could step by step
to back away toward the mantelpiece
the other mother pushed down on the door
handle and pulled open the door
revealing a corridor behind it dark and
empty
there she said waving her hands at the
corridor
the expression of delight on her face
was a very bad
thing to see you're wrong
you don't know where your parents are do
you
they aren't there she turned and looked
at coraline
now she said you're going to stay here
forever and always
no said coraline i'm not
and as hard as she could she threw the
black cat toward the other mother
it yelled and landed on the mother's
head claws flailing
teeth bared fierce and angry fur on end
it looked half again as big as it was in
real life without waiting to see what
would happen coraline reached up to the
mantelpiece
and closed her hand around the snow
globe pushing it deep into the pocket of
her dressing gown
the cat made a deep eulating the owl
and sank its teeth into the other
mother's cheek
she was flailing at it blood ran from
the cuts on her white face
not red blood but a deep tarry
black stuff coraline ran for the door
she pulled the key out of the lock leave
her come on
she shouted to the cat it hissed and
swiped its scalpel sharp claws at the
other mother's face
in one wild rake which left black ooze
trickling from several gashes on the
other mother's nose
then it sprang down toward coraline
quickly
she said the cat ran toward her
and they both stepped into the dark
corridor
it was colder in the corridor like
stepping down into a cellar
on a warm day the cat hesitated for a
moment then seeing the other mother was
coming toward them
it ran to coraline and stopped by her
legs
coraline began to pull the door closed
it was heavier than she imagined a door
could be and pulling it closed was like
trying to close a door against a high
wind
and then she felt something from the
other side starting to pull against her
shut she thought then she said out loud
come on please
and she felt the door begin to move to
pull closed to give
against the phantom wind
suddenly she was aware of other people
in the corridor with her
she could not turn her head to look at
them but she knew them without having to
look help me please
all of you she said
the other people in the corridor three
children
two adults were somehow too
insubstantial to touch the door
but their hands closed about hers as she
pulled on the big
iron door handle and suddenly she felt
strong
never let up miss hold strong hold
strong
whispered a voice in her mind pool girl
pull
whispered another and then a voice
that sounded like her mother's her own
mother
her real wonderful maddening
infuriating glorious mother
just said well done coraline
and that was enough the doors started to
slip closed
easily as anything no
screamed a voice from beyond the door
and it no longer sounded even faintly
human
something snatched at coraline reaching
through the closing gap between the door
and the doorpost
coraline jerked her head out of the way
but the door began to open once more
we're going to go home said coraline we
are help me
she ducked the snatching fingers
they moved through her then ghost hands
lent her strength that she no longer
possessed
there was a final moment of resistance
as if something were caught
in the door and then with a crash
the wooden door banged closed
something dropped from coraline's head
height to the floor
and it landed with a sort of scuttling
thump
come on said the cat this is not a good
place to be in
quickly coraline turned her back on the
door and began to run
as fast as was practical through the
dark corridor running her hand along the
wall to make sure she didn't bump into
anything
or get turned around in the darkness it
was an
uphill run and it seemed to her that it
went on for a longer distance than
anything could possibly go
the wall she was touching felt warm and
yielding now and she realized it felt as
if it were covered in a
fine downy fur it moved
as if it were taking a breath she
snatched her hand away from it
winds howled in the dark she was scared
she would bump into something
and she put out her hand for the wall
once more this time when she
touched felt hot and wet as if she had
put her hand in somebody's mouth
and she pulled it back with a small
whale
her eyes had adjusted to the dark she
could half see
as faintly glowing patches ahead of her
two adults
three children she could hear the cat
too
padding in the dark in front of her and
there was something else
which suddenly scuttled between her feet
nearly sending coraline flying she
caught herself before she went down
using her own momentum to keep moving
she knew that if she fell in that
corridor she might never get up again
whatever that corridor was was older by
far than the other mother
it was deep and slow
and it knew that she was there
then daylight appeared and she ran
toward it
puffing and wheezing almost there
she called encouragingly but in the
light she discovered that the wraiths
had gone
and she was alone she did not have time
to wonder what had happened to them
panting for breath she staggered through
the door
and slammed it behind her with the
loudest most satisfying bang
you can imagine
coraline locked the door with the key
and put the key back into her pocket
the black cat was huddled in the
farthest corner of the room
the pink tip of its tongue showing its
eyes
wide coralline went over to it and
crouched down beside it
i'm sorry she said i'm sorry i threw you
at her but
it was the only way to distract her
enough to get us all out
she would never have kept her word would
she
the cat looked up at her then rested its
head on her hand
licking her fingers with its sandpapery
tongue
it began to purr and
were friends said coraline
she sat down on one of her grandmother's
uncomfortable arm chairs
and the cat sprang into her lap and made
itself comfortable
the light that came through the picture
window was daylight
real golden late afternoon daylight
not a white mist light and the sky was a
robin's egg blue
and coraline could see trees and beyond
the trees green hills
which faded on the horizon into purples
and grays
the sky had never seen so sky
the world had never seemed so
whirled coraline stared at the leaves on
the trees
and at the patterns of light and shadow
on the cracked bark of the trunk of the
beech tree outside the window
then she looked down at her lap at the
way that the rich sunlight brushed every
hair in the cat's head
turning each white whisker to gold
nothing she thought
had ever been so interesting
and caught up in the interestingness of
the world
coraline barely noticed that she had
wriggled down and curled
catlike on her grandmother's
uncomfortable armchair
nor did she notice when she fell into a
deep
and dreamless sleep
you